thank you
[Music]
so there's this guy and he's selling a
hoodie on Facebook Marketplace
and then he screenshots his conversation
with the person that wants to buy it
because it is very remarkable what
happens remarkable what happened word
from Ryan he's got this hoodie that's um
I guess it's kind of rare so he's
selling it for like 140 and then uh this
girl responds and goes hey
yes
so she goes um how about how about I I
give you a little extra favor and then
you discount me
uh the price let me tell you something
dude I fantasize about things like this
every day
[Laughter]
every day yeah all right and it's always
a yes and I always feel like who are
these lucky guys who are getting these
[__] mess here read read it out loud
this is so this is you gotta sell more
stuff on Poshmark being a girl this is
what the girl's saying to the guy I'm
gonna be a little yeah
I'm gonna be a little cheeky would you
do 110 and a [__] on collection
thirty dollars off [__] I got it my
friend but if you can keep it a secret
okay
wow 30 if not I'll go get you cash what
do you think he said in response
you should send me a photo
oh that's that's very good that's
probably that's probably the best but
Facebook is skewed sometimes that's
probably the next best thing so he'll
know what she's on his Instagram
Facebook Marketplace first of all blow
job messenger so if I got that message
I'm a [__] because I'd be like this is
a setup and I delete the message
or something yeah not even under covers
like yeah I'm gonna get robbed yeah Rob
you're [__] robbed or some [__]
is it till I finish oh good question I'm
gonna be too nervous and not even get
hard yeah do we get coffee first how
about I eat you out no the sweater is
170.
dude
I think he said yes if he's a real one
but the real one but if he's like
there's this thing you gotta look at
keywords yeah she was cheeky yeah she's
from She's British British
he's a white guy
well first of all I don't even know how
to say that ew Europe
um
he's good
um sorry and haven't had that offer
before funny though I'm gay so I'll take
the cash unless your boyfriend's
interested wow what a good answer what a
waste is that a waste every guy's
fantasy and it actually happens but it
doesn't [__] match yeah dude well
maybe because she thought he was
handsome and clean
I'll still get a discount from being
nice oh that's still a way so because
she looks like a [__] for saying I have
a boyfriend keep a secret please yeah
but maybe the boyfriend like maybe he
did the deed
maybe she convinced him
which is why it's cool to talk about it
you know a 40 discount
30 dude imagine you're not even gay but
you'll suck another day so your girl can
buy a hoodie at thirty dollars less even
though she or she said it first speaking
about the guy
um babe can come in the kitchen real
quick um can you do me a favor what what
I don't want to [__] do it
thirty dollars you're like fine [__]
cashmere
it's for me you don't get [__] for me
all right
has anything like this ever happened to
you where you were offered something
yeah gay guys blow me all the time dude
not for a discount but offered sex in
exchange for something
let me tell you something oh go ahead
bro I need to hear this what this old
came from this is crazy I was in high
school uh I was living with my dad I
think I was 15 or 16. yes my dad rents
out the other two rooms two roommates
From This Moment On take your time
that couldn't make rent
my dad told me he's gonna kick her out
like next week or whatever
uh four or five in the morning she comes
and knocks on my door she comes huh
because your dad's gonna kick me out is
there anything I can do
for you to convince him to to let me
stay whoa and I was like I don't think
you know our relationship
[__] what what's your age difference at
this point I don't know she was nasty
though oh 60. don't know is there
anything you can do you're on the story
for me I think I was I think I was 16
and she had double D's I think oh that's
not bad dang dude and she was like 16
and a half so it was like kind of cool
for you she was like
oh [__] definitely it's going south
highly illegal too yeah it was it was
illegal it was one of the good foot
massages though
maybe that's what she meant like I'm
Really Gonna reflex that's what she was
insinuating
I think at 4am in the morning
and then she was I don't think she was
wearing a bra either like just hear
things pointing around in there they
were moving so I was like
[__] close the door you just close
the door
she said is there anything I can do and
you're like and she ended up getting
kicked out hey rant [__]
close the door that's weird how come she
didn't do that to your dad
maybe she did I don't know
but it was it was maybe she just did and
then I tried my son I don't know that's
good
try that guy he's a [__] person
anyways
oh I don't think I got a oh boy your dad
just set that up for you oh I know he's
[__] made you [__]
definitely weird because when someone's
knocking on your room like at 4am in the
morning when you wake up you're like
what the [__] happening what the hell
is happening you know yeah and then so
when you open the door okay it's the
roommates long time what do you want you
think like her car broke down or
something you know and she's like is
there anything I could do to you know
stay is her hand up like that yeah she's
trying to be here you couldn't tell if
she's trying to be seductive in as much
as a 99 Ranch lady Can Be You Can Tell
She's trying to be seductive she had
some Teresa tang in the background
what's up for a game then like she
should have had a [__] radish or
something a rash yeah baby yeah that was
that was that was really weird that's
the only time wow never some
for some British fantasy I never had
them the only thing that was weird like
that was when my this girl would go to
the house and we go swimming and they
were gonna sister that was like 17 we're
like all like 50 no
[__] we're like in sixth grade what is
that anyways that's not the point the
point of the story is demons that she
was like talking about like we heard her
talking to her friend talking about
she's giving like [__] at school and
then I was like what the hell remember
all my homies were like even though
we're sixth grade we're like from the
hood so we like felt older so we're like
oh [__] how about you suck our dicks
and she was like she's like I was like I
would have you ever got your dick sucked
and I was like
let me see I suck your dick right now
and I'm like oh [__]
or in front of everyone so she was just
like yeah let's see then let's see I
think she she you know she knew I was
gonna be you know I didn't want to move
my dick dude like that sixth grade
because you're looking I didn't want to
pull my baby dick out you guys have to
put the homies like they're all gonna
first now everybody's gonna be like yo
that's your dick dog you know what I
mean that was gonna be like so I was
like I'm not confident it wasn't there
yet it is uh is it gonna keep growing
luckily it hasn't but I'll say maybe
he's getting some you know some more
growth and [__] and I just was too
afraid to do it but she called me out
told me to whip it out she was just
gonna do it she would have but I
remember I just Frozen I was like oh
you're crazy like in the room
Roman [__] down it's just like right
here nothing like in the room
all right but dude's gonna scare
everyone okay
that's the only time I ever got offer
like a [__] like that you know how we
Throw the uh in front of the annual
Halloween party and then we don't we
it's it's very strictly guest list only
yeah and then uh one time we were
throwing it at the Parlor in Hollywood
and one of the bartender girls like
invited some friends to like come and
they got stopped at the front and they
were like oh no it's like invite only
and then uh then she called me over and
she was like can you let my friends in
I'm like no I don't know him and she's
like I will suck your dick if you just
let these guys in please
and then they came in I feel like you're
the type of guy that's like and it was a
great party
that's a good answer no I just let him
in I swear right you're wild you look at
that type of guy who's like I need you
to get the [__] out of my face